[Music]
in back in my day news welcome our boy I
can't wait to say that I feel like I'm
turning into that [ __ ] right now dude
been saying that all their Oh different
different type of way a little more
condemning yeah submitted by y'all
beautiful oh lucky there are eight
things kids born in 2018 will never
experience thanks to technology hey
folks
oh yeah like 30 pictures that one and
then the like when you call someone it's
like busy like the you know who does
that my [ __ ] dad he doesn't pay for
call waiting [ __ ] loser when I call
him so if he's on the phone with some
relatives in Asia when I call him it's
like beep beep beep and I'll keep
calling back every 30 minutes I know
he's having my two hour long
conversation and he doesn't even pay for
call waiting he bills probably a $2.00
upgrade or something well be seen in the
airports they switch out all the pay
phones to like charging yes charging
station kids will never remember that
like that's where you would pay 25 cents
yeah well from this list we're talking
about kids that are born in this year
that will be 18 like 18 years from now
my gosh yeah that's like Tigers
generation but he's 2017 so is one year
older than all those guys yeah he's
gonna be using no three months more
information than everybody else he
doesn't know what a pager is there's no
one who's right now is poor vision
number one paper money by the time
people born today they will not know
paper money really Dom but it feels all
good I don't want paper money to
disappear
I don't either because there is nothing
like having a stack of cash and slapping
it on a bare ass they're gonna go to the
strip club and [ __ ] make it rain by
going like that I know so boy what if
they okay pal you and demo
kinda like took your cheese tickets but
bigger and then like these chips but
like just cash oh don't make it rain but
then they strippers and that right there
is a assumption okay but it's a goal of
almost every country though I mean China
is already pretty much cashless so it's
a it's a pretty educated cryptocurrency
2020 but I feel like America is pretty
late on the game I mean come on
yeah we litter everything so number two
getting a driver's license driver's
license everything's gonna be automated
well because there's a [ __ ] ton of
self-driving cars and then the rise of
helicopter parents and concerns about
personal safety I cannot wait to the day
I don't ever have to drive you're doing
that right now I still have to drive a
Tesla
what's the helicopter parent always like
kids I think I'm send the driver to do
up no you're not I am I don't let Isaac
have a like I don't let that's not a
helicopter blower the Internet
I don't let him if he's on the bicycle I
don't let him go out on the street no no
that what kind of parent are you if you
go on his browser and you purposely make
porno sites as new bookmarks my friends
like that so I'm just figuring out
you're not gonna go fast
you're called the absent parent dude
yeah so they're saying that by 2036
which is 18 years from now the vast
majority of cars will be self-driving
and oh wait driver's license anymore how
boring oh [ __ ] dude just to go in my car
and just be like alright I'm just gonna
go and then it just takes me there that
means I could do whatever the [ __ ] I
want with in my car and not worry about
[ __ ] that's been also accident aren't my
fault oh yeah you keep it alive like
exactly stupid robots fault you have no
words you know what they're saying that
traffic will be gone if everything was
automated not beat I know people really
good for here because everything's like
it'll be like ants everything's like and
we all feel each other's cars and they
never bump into no accident yep
everything's in uni and you don't have
to [ __ ] people that go on a [ __ ]
red light behind another car but instead
of going right behind them they're like
three cars behind them I'm ready I hate
that here does that among this it irks
me like crazy she stops the minute she
starts seeing the stop sign just
creeping all the way and tell us about
that's still okay I just hit one there's
like a car here and then the other cars
in forward hearts between yeah that's so
rude for the people because when they do
that in in the freeway and there's
[ __ ] truck here I always go through
if you can see that hard for any back
tires you're good you're as far as you
need to be yeah um I was really thinking
about it like when my lease is up I'm
just gonna over everywhere
that's tight cuz I just don't like
driving I [ __ ] hate it so you never
get the creepos know do you guys ever
get the creepos I'm the people every
single over a driver I get is a creep oh
you know what I wish though I wish I was
I would be able to ball out and every
[ __ ] order is just like a seven eight
passenger SUV and I'm the only person
sitting in the battle they'll be the
spike but tell me about those people one
of them asked me there it started off
with me having a banana or no having a
water bottle you can't you started the
conversation right when you went to the
banana and you're like hi I looked him
in the eye no no I put the water bottle
away and I'm like don't worry I'm not
gonna leave my trash and he goes oh the
guy before you left a banana and I was
like I didn't think anything about it
but then he's like he left all his other
trash and I said some people just don't
know social norms yeah and he jumped
from that to say he was with this girl
who was talking about how she makes
money doing social media stuff so then
he thought she was just a call girl who
wasn't calling herself a call girl
so then he jumps into how he's sex
therapist and then he talks about how he
gets a lot of girls who come to LA with
big dreams who turn to porn because I
get paid a lot because they don't have
self
confident and this whole time I'm like
he just wants to talk to me about his
sex addiction that's all he talks about
oh you're trying to work you he was
trying to work you or you just want the
vent so my Oberer wasn't working so my
husband called me an uber so I came out
of his car with a bag of clothes so I
looked like I don't know maybe he
thought in his head I was a call girl
yeah it was like commas turnigy yes and
then the second one as soon as my friend
we took the same uber she got out and
out of [ __ ] nowhere the guy goes I
just want to get so ripped that she
takes the split in her chest her dress
rips it all the way up and has sex with
me and I'm like thank you always letters
hi I wish that would happen to me wait
how he wants to get so ripped he's like
I just want to get so yeah like jacked
like in shape Adam sometimes I'll have
you trying to talk to my uber driver and
they tell me to be quiet I'm like hey
guy how are you doing he goes not today
man
all right buddy my girlfriend used to
drive uber and lyft and then a guy asked
her how much an appropriate super I was
like you should have said [ __ ] five
you get number three
getting a weekend job will no longer be
a thing that kids born today will be
doing I don't even know what the [ __ ]
that is what is a weekend job so you
know like back in the day you'll get
your driver's license at 17 and then
you'll get a job at like the burger
joint at McDonald's or something - fill
Monday through Friday yeah and get a
weekend job and so they're saying that
in 1980 70 percent of teens had summer
jobs today it's about 40% and it's
falling so less and less teens are
getting jobs and especially with like if
you give it another 18 years there's
gonna be robots doing a lot of this [ __ ]
that teens are doing that's really
changes to bag groceries but the
knowledge is gonna be all automated so
that all job opportunities have changed
now you know so those those like
part-time jobs like some people didn't
even want to have to finish high school
to have a working job and have a family
in a house back
the day so that's that's a different
story completely you know what I mean
so yeah I don't I don't think that
really equates what are they gonna do
for war
seriously they're making their parents
forever social media like you narrate
apps apps for everything yes they're
gonna create apps all right number four
language barriers there will be well tie
toward barriers because those
translators yeah there's a [ __ ] you know
like translators you're just putting
into your ear and then it speaks to
people that speak differently I keep
telling myself I want to learn a [ __ ]
third language but so what language
Swahili how long have you known us for
huh how long have you known us for seven
years that's how long you've been saying
don't you know you don't ever eat goals
yep oh that's funny who's the one that
made a movie in this room no actually it
was me and him together so that's the
[ __ ] goal right there anyways
all right the next one thing is one
thing in one place is the next one which
means I face that [ __ ] as elementary
school I can't [ __ ] sit still for
[ __ ] means traveling travel more they
will be traveling way more especially
with Elon Musk how he proposes having
these rockets that will take you
anywhere in the planet for in less than
an hour so [ __ ] creepy yeah so then
by the time our kids reach 18 everyone
will be just jump in between the entire
world you're saying a lot of my dreams
though like I don't want to drive and I
want to travel somewhere really quick
that's that's just just it yeah they
didn't care what a TSA though because it
might take you an hour to get to [ __ ]
Paris for hours still don't even get on
the rocket because they were talking
about the public transportation when
they were saying that you can get from
San Francisco to LA or whatever yeah
yeah like that was supposed to happen
and we dipped a lot of money into that
[ __ ] so I wouldn't mind like living in
Sacramento and this traveling to LA
every [ __ ] day if I have to
have a new it no it they took like a
billion dollars for it like so it's not
built yet
right exactly are they working on that
but that's that's Elon Musk [ __ ] though
no this is like a government thing
they're supposed to build a train how
much are the rocket tickets gonna cost
them I mean I'm saying like that's gonna
be expensive this affordable no I was
like going to New York like an economic
economic plane ticket yeah anyway next
time you're dying before 100 that will
no longer be a thing oh yeah people are
living longer now it's technology
inventing new drugs even if people are
living a reckless lifestyle well I mean
it was gonna be that ultra carbon [ __ ]
you look at all the rich people
there's livin long and they're [ __ ]
reckless oh wait how old was Hugh heavy
what he passed away [ __ ] him dinosaur 7
Oh 87 something like that it was my baby
because if I lived up to his age and his
life it's not bad because you're so very
coherent that's okay you know I just
want to be like let me see your mind and
your body exactly I don't want like be
Julie until you know but the way things
are going he was 91 dang I was way off
my grandpa was 97 or 98 when he passed
away yeah it was almost a hundred that
old [ __ ] yeah imagine all of us though
being 100 being like what are we gonna
do count like what's funny no you get to
travel all over the planet your body at
a hundred at seventy I don't understand
like now it's gonna be better because of
all on YouTube
yeah you could replace your bones with
titanium metal
yeah like 3d printed by 97 and 98 years
old dude like I feel like every day I
wake up I'm just saying
guess I'm not dead cuz like you're
expecting to die at that point
everything you would still do [ __ ] you
know yeah chill number seven is having
any privacy that will be gone what's
happening like the whole Cambridge and
Alec
Facebook debacle we like steak they took
like all the Facebook information like
they know everything about your life
through that I think I'd go find privacy
you know nothing so there's nothing
going off the grid they can't like
they're saying that in 18 years from now
it's gonna be impossible to have any
privacy I know a couple of places in
this world that has no reception
one is the elevator one is the elevator
and the other one is also Shinsengumi no
reception ever you know it blew my mind
usually the casino floor has no
reception but at the Aria that [ __ ] was
on point I was like yeah yeah all right
the last one on his list is living in a
world with poverty that will be gone
yeah really I thought cuz there's like
way nude there's new types of food
lab-grown meat genetically modified
crops I mean we could do away with world
hunger right now we can do it now no one
wants to do it yeah we have way more
than enough food yeah there should be no
hunger no but the problem is getting it
there they just can't move it move it
click yeah I'm so excited to see what
the world's gonna be like though in 2036
cuz just look 18 years back from today
it wasn't bad that's kidding was it 18
mm that's when everyone thought the
world was gonna end
yeah I remember we stocked up anybody
like I did not stock up my dad said it
was a bunch of [ __ ] he was right
yeah my dad's like [ __ ] well what is
an expression of Venice like it was like
why two kids you still wouldn't have
apologized he wouldn't be like ah Shh
no you just been like come on he's
Korean would you was gonna happen yeah I
know
didn't I tell you you got lucky
your 2000 minute y2k people like bought
all the [ __ ] downer bottles they
bought all the supplies out of Walmart
it was 18 years no one will remember y2k
and what that stood for oh yeah I was
y2k so scary
it was very saying the computer binary
code or some [ __ ] like that all right
and it was gonna reset and it was gonna
be like [ __ ] everything because of the
zeros something no because they forgot
to input y2k or some [ __ ] like that
right like that was one of the we were
totally fine I don't know we made it we
survived we survived y2k
[Music]